let's go next to our caller from the
three-30 area code caller from three
three zero
go ahead hi I'm Zach from Ohio great go
ahead Zach okay so I have this idea for
her gun control and I was wondering what
you thought of it okay so I'm not too
keen on magazine in limit bans ends and
stuff like that because they don't seem
to have much impact on actually reducing
crime so how did you determine that how
did you determine that limiting the
number of bullets someone can fire
without reloading doesn't have an impact
on crime I have seen studies where it
shows that people tend to just reload
and it doesn't really make much impact
maybe I'm I'm wrong on that you're
talking about in mass shooting scenarios
yeah and I'd love to solve that day out
because what I'm saying I mean mass
shootings are rare enough that there's
usually quite a bit of information and
it it seems as though there's there's
data to suggest that the reload phase is
often where the mass shooting is stopped
so I'd want to see that data but go
ahead like I said maybe I'm wrong on
that yes but also mass shootings are
rare as you said no they're not they're
really not that I mean on foot they're
rare enough that we know about them rare
if you actually look at the gun violence
archive with the way mass shootings are
defined
there's shockingly many like you would
be shocked at how many mass shootings
there were just yesterday yeah because
there's with it only being uh for people
that need to be injured you know great
but uh I I believe that it we should
there should be some sort of of a
punishment for people who who are not
handling uh they're not a safe gun owner
people who do not know for instance lock
up their guns and a gun safe
I think if their gun gets stolen and
then used in a shooting I think there
should be some sort of punished
and for that yeah I agree and you know I
think that that infrastructure already
exists in some states but it's just very
rarely actually enforced but yeah I I
agree with you to me it's not hugely
controversial but there were people on
the gun rights fetishist side who would
say these are restrictions they are
extra constitutional so it's an
interesting idea it's not a unique idea
and I say that with total peace and love
it's just more about getting getting the
gun rights people to go along with it
and a lot of them will not but I do
appreciate the call appreciate the idea